und jetzt meine damen und herren ist es
höchste zeit für ein großes ja denn im
erzbistum köln heißt es habemus
missbrauchs gutachten nach jahrzehnten
der organisierten vertuschung immerhin
eine gute nachricht
zwei kölner weihbischof und der chef des
kirchen gerichts können jetzt sonntags
länger schlafen beurlaubt kardinal
woelki selber sagt das gutachten ist
aber nichts vorzuwerfen
also was kirchen und strafrecht angeht
moralisch darf man das durchaus anders
sehen woelkis mentor ein inzwischen
verstorbener düsseldorfer priester soll
ein kindergartenkind vergewaltigt haben
vorwürfe von denen woelki wusste die
aber nie nach rom gemeldet hat weil er
fand der mann sei schon zu gebrechlich
ist aber alles kein rücktrittsgrund so
ein rücktritt wäre nur ein symbol des
höchstens für eine kurze zeit hält doch
machst doch trotzdem freue ich mich kurz
seit dieser woche ist auch das gutachten
einsehbar dass woelki monatelang
zurückgehalten hat und jetzt ahnt man
auch warum weil da auch moralische
urteile gefällt werden
es wird systemische kritik an der kirche
geübt stichwort zusammenhang zwischen
zölibat und missbrauch ekliger fakt am
rande kirchenrechtlich wird
kindesmissbrauch also die vergewaltigung
von kindern bei denen als verstoß gegen
das zölibat gewertet ist so weil
priesterjahr mit gott verheiratet sind
eine ehe mit gott wie habe ich mir das
vorzustellen ich habe guckst du von
wieder wolfs kids und wolltest doch den
müll rausbringen
jeden sonntag in die kirche wenn wir
nicht ein wahrer vom unternehmen
[Musik]
ich habe mein browserverlauf gecheckt
gott ist jetzt wieder zu ihrer mutter
gezogen
übrigens benennt das neue kölner
gutachten einen hauptschuldigen nämlich
den früheren kardinal meisner und der
hat für die rolle einen entscheidenden
vorteil er ist tot
ihm werden 24 sogenannte
pflichtverletzungen vorgeworfen
klingt ein bisschen nach ups schon
wieder die spülmaschine nicht ausgeräumt
meint aber hier eigentlich die
verschleierung von schwerem
kindesmissbrauch eine tat für die
meister in seinen akten damals
bedrückend poetische worte findet er ist
bischof dr meißner führte nach angaben
des erzbistums zusätzlich einen
separaten aktenordner mit dem schönen
titel brüder im nebel in dem er
geheimhaltungs bedürftige unterlagen
aufbewahrte brüder im nebel als wäre das
wetter schuld die kirche hat doch für
den entsprechenden nebel selber gesorgt
ja im fachgeschäft für priester bedarf
gab es damals spezielle soutanen mit
eingebauter nebelmaschine total
praktisch wenn man wieder was macht was
keiner sehen soll
täterschutz ging in dem laden immer vor
opferschutz noch im jahr 2009 10 nicht
lange her hatte die kirche nur sieben
prozent der überführten kinderschänder
selber zur anzeige gebracht woelki war
meisters geheim sekretär beharrt aber
darauf die missbrauchs vertuschung aber
der chef vor ihm geheim gehalten warum
das einer glauben soll das bleibt wohl
sein geheimnis
kardinal meisner wirklich ein legendäres
kölsches original sagt immer eine
familie von euch ersetzt mir drei
muslimische familien und ich sag immer
ein rassistischer kardinal ersetzt mir
drei afd politiker meister kann man
nicht mehr belangen der hat durch sein
ableben ein wasserdichtes attest dafür
musste hamburger erzbischof stefan heße
sein amt ruhen lassen
genau wie die kölner weihbischöfe
dominikus schwaderlapp
ansgar puff der ist nicht in barcelona
wir hatten einfach bock auf das
wortspiel entschuldigung auch
schwaderlapp und tuff werden die
erwähnten pflichtverletzungen
vorgeworfen
sie waren teil des vertuschungs systems
quasi nach dem motto gib wird gut bleibt
die frage was machen so arbeitslose
kölner weihbischof eigentlich den ganzen
tag
schuldig in not geraten kein problem
kommen sie zu vertuschen reich
schwaderlapp und beruf wie vor duschen
hierfür je wieder mal zu führen messwein
am steuer
schwamm drüber wir brauchten einfach es
war ein verstorbener gardiner mitte jung
citywire raucht war den nebel geschieht
bleibt im nebel um im kirchenzelt alle
jahre wieder ärger mit den eltern keine
panik als hätt noch immer jot jejange
bestreitet ihre straftat ab das im puff
und schwager da ich würde sie buchen
gleichzeitig erleben wir gerade einen
regelrechten kulturkampf vatikan versus
deutsche katholiken dazu muss man wissen
für die hardcore fraktionen da in rom
ist unsere deutsche bischofskonferenz
sowas wie ja wie eine linke
hippie-kommune weil die bischöfe zum
beispiel mit katholischen laien über
reformen diskutieren über die rolle der
frau sexualität diese ganzen
schweinereien um den wahnsinn mal
auszubremsen hat die sogenannte
glaubenskongregation im vatikan nun
verkündet gleichgeschlechtliche paare
dürfen nicht gesegnet werden punkt ja
die folge der größte deutsche kirchen
auf stand seit luther neulich deutsche
bischöfe beschweren sich öffentlich also
wölkchen natürlich nicht aber viele
andere ja man sieht regenbogenfahnen an
kirchen regenbogen socken im
gottesdienst wie bei diesem fahrer in
recklinghausen oder regenbogen logos auf
der facebook-seite von bis zum limburg
ein segen für homosexuelle sagt also der
vatikan ganz offiziell
und wir schalten live nach rom zu
monstern lloris sebastian pufpaff von
der glaubenskongregation ich sehe das
ist bei ihnen schon wieder
außengastronomie
das weiß ich gar nicht mehr der ganze
booms gehirns doch weil das ja alles
hier privatgelände
hier ist vatikan das gamle italien das
fängt irgendwo dahinten nach vorne
wahrscheinlich so zur frage die sich mir
wahrscheinlich stellen werden warum kein
segen für homosexuelle ganz einfach weil
das sex außerhalb der ehe ist danke fürs
gespräch in und schön aber das ist aber
nur sex außerhalb der ehe weil die
homosexuellen bei euch keine ehe
eingehen dürfen
da brauchen wir aber eine hexe das ist
ja wohl jetzt hier ernst kirchliche
trauung für homosexuelle unser super
moderner franziskus ist auch schon an
die absolute tabelle runs grenze
gegangen als er gesagt hat wenn jemand
schwul ist aber den herrn sucht und
guten willens ist leben ich ihn zu
richten
hier das ist es nämlich kleiner finger
direkt ganz sachen der gemeine homo
könnte auch mal dankbar sein dass wir
die nicht mehr richten und was haben wir
die früher gerichtet du hast alle drei
meter gegoogelt
das stimmt ihre glaubenskongregation ist
ja tatsächlich der offizielle
nachfolgeverein der inquisition ja das
stimmt klar
und das ist auch eine verantwortung ich
meine das niveau muss auch erstmal
halten herr wilke
was den segen angeht da sind wir ja
schon verdammt großzügig verdammt witzig
sie glauben gar nicht was von meinen
kollegen alles gesehen hat wird im
landkreis donau ries wird diesmal ein
segen gespendet für alle tiere die mit
ihren besitzern gekommen sind autos aber
die liebe von zwei menschen nicht ja und
in köln wurde sogar ein neues gitter vor
dem dom gesegnet damit die besoffenen
nicht mehr am kirchenschiff pinkeln
können oder dieser deutsche kollege der
sieg mit autos in vorbeifahren sogar
elektroautos obwohl die auch total
schwul sind
ich verstehe das alles nicht in
deutschland werden von euch regelmäßig
autobahn teilstücke gesegnet es ist halt
unsere aufgabe gottes segen zu
portionieren und an die richtigen zu
verteilen
seien wir doch mal bitte ehrlich selbst
wenn ich jetzt so ein homosexuellen
segnen würde
ende landet der ja trotzdem in der hölle
so gesehen ist das segens verschwinden
es ist immer dasselbe neuer papst sagt
sachen die irgendwie modern klingen
und dann kam leute wie sie aus der
deckung und stehen die uhren wieder auf
mittelalter da wird sich nie was ändern
ja aber warum auch warum soll sie hier
irgendwas ändern ich gucken sie sich
dass man lage lage lage luigi das abo
spitze hupe und bis er fertig ist hören
wir zur erbauung das kardinal meisner
terzett mit einem frechen modernen
gospels
[Musik]
ob esel oder kuh
wir segnen allen
tiere
nur eines ist haben
wir sind keine
das war bei
ach so
wir segnen keinen
ist
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye